thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story a red card for Gary
lineker has the BBC takes their star
presenter off the pitch for his
criticism of the government
[Music]
his fellow pundits pull out of match of
the day in protest as they and
opposition politicians attack the BBC's
decision
also tonight nearly half a billion
pounds to try to stop small boats the
prime minister's Summit pledge for
France's president
the drivers stuck in the snow as the
country Shivers and with more weather
warnings on the way
game over we see the virtual Warfare for
real life pilots and soldiers
[Music]
thank you very much
the ultimate birthday present for Prince
Edward the new Duke of Edinburgh
following in the footsteps of his father
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening one of the most famous
faces on British television says he has
been taken off air by the BBC after he
criticized the government over its small
boat's policy Gary lineker will step
back from presenting match of the day
the corporation said the decision was
criticized by opposition politicians and
perhaps more importantly for his program
his pundits a succession of which say
they also will refuse to appear in the
last hour the BBC has said its football
highlights will go ahead but without any
presenters more on that in a moment but
first our correspondent Ashner huronag
reports
within three days Gary lineker has gone
for one of the BBC's most loved faces to
one we won't be seeing anytime soon
taken off air for breaching the
organization's impartiality rules
we've said that we consider his recent
social media activity to be a breach of
our guidelines the BBC has decided that
he will step back from presenting match
of the day until we've gotten agreed and
clear position on his use of social
media when it comes to Leading our
football and sports coverage they say
Gary is second to none we have never
said that Gary should be an opinion-free
zone or that he can't have a view on
issues that matter to him but we have
said that he should keep well away from
taking sides on party political issues
or political controversies
also close to the presenter though says
this decision to step back wasn't his at
all instead one taken solely by the
corporation he's also not willing to
apologize for his comments so there's a
standoff and one that's causing quite
the headache for those Insider
in solidarity former footballers and
fellow broadcasters Ian Wright Alan
Shearer and Alex Scott are refusing to
appear on the program a Fallout that's
snowballing when the corporation would
have wanted it quashed well I can see
the BBC has a dilemma it has a presenter
who does want to say whatever he wants
to say but the BBC is saying we have
never said that Gary should be an
opinion-free Zone all that he can't have
a view on issues that matter to him and
I think that is going all in sort of
territory it's very difficult to work
out what he can he and can't he say so
this is really from the BBC's point of
view a terrible and rather sad mess at
the moment it all started on Tuesday
with this tweet criticizing the
government's latest migration plan and
comparing its language to that used in
1930s Germany
the day after the broadcaster whose Long
supported refugees doubled down on his
views and the government then hit back
with the Home Secretary branding his
language offensive and his name propping
up in the Commons
labor are borrowing from the Gary
lineker Playbook they are a party of
gold hangers and the occasional
left-wing Striker
which yet again ignited a response
it's led to a sanctioned some sea as
appropriate I wouldn't want to silence
anybody's opinions I know he'll argue
that he's not a politics presenter or a
news presenter or so on but he's clearly
overstepped the marker I mean what he
said was grossly offensive and he
doesn't seem to be showing any
Contrition for that whatsoever whilst
colleagues of linekers are ramping up
support in asking one of its most
popular faces to step back the BBC is
stepping towards more division
Sky News
well our Sports correspondent Rob Harris
is at the BBC's headquarters tonight and
Rob so many headaches for the BBC the
first of which is what to do with match
of the day tomorrow they do have a plan
though
yes but they've had to rip up the format
for a six decade footballing institution
there will be no presenter there will be
no pundits and there will be no Studio
expats at all if the BBC hope that
dropping Gary lineker would defuse this
crisis well the Mutiny amongst the
pundits and his colleague certainly
suggested otherwise we had Alan Shearer
and others announcing that they would
not take part in a show without Gary
lineker on Saturday night and it's
unclear even if commentators will still
provide the voice for those games so the
show can go ahead Sky News is also just
learning that players in the Premier
League are forming a collective position
about whether they go ahead and give
interviews to the BBC so a situation
that has a far reaching ramifications
within broadcasting but far deeper so as
well within the BBC there's a sense in
the building behind me of potential
double standards we've seen internal
messages from within the BBC that point
out if the BBC does care about impartial
reality which this whole Saga is about
well why does their ultimate boss the
chairman of the BBC Richard Sharp in get
himself involved in facilitating loans
for prime ministers we had this with the
former prime minister Boris Johnson with
Revelations that emerged in recent weeks
that raised questions about his own
position within the political sphere so
really questions go beyond the
footballing aspect the presents
presentation aspect tonight and these
messages that were understanding show
the unease and that disquiet within the
BBC and as we see this is something now
that the BBC has to decide where it goes
to next the more immediate question is
what happens to match of the day on
Saturday night does it air and then the
BBC has to decide the future of its
highest paid and most high profile
presenter Gary lineker and where he
stays at the corporation
indeed Rob thank you very much for the
moment
now it's quite a bill to try to end this
Small Boat Crossings on the French side
but it was agreed today by Rishi sunak
meeting France's president in Paris the
Prime Minister announced the UK would
give almost half a billion pounds to the
French over the next three years it's a
huge step up in support in contrast the
UK committed 232 million pounds to
migrant agreements covering the past
nine years
some of this money will go towards
building a Detention Center in northern
France it will also fund hundreds of new
French Patrol officers and provide
enhanced patrolling technology like
drones
all the way from small boats the two
leaders also pledge to coordinate the
supply of weapons to Ukraine and the
training of Ukrainian Marines and agreed
to a new energy partnership and deal on
civil nuclear energy our Deputy
political editor Sam coats reports from
Paris
arriving in Paris promising a new
beginning his predecessor couldn't say
if Emmanuel macron was a true Ally in
front of prime minister
this new prime minister in little doubt
the warmest of handshakes in the
courtyard of the Elysee Palace this the
first summit of its kind since 2018 both
leaders Keen to show the world that this
is a diplomatic bromance
a brief pose for the cameras but soon
Alone Together the president and prime
minister spent an hour in talks with no
aides or officials in the room
top of the agenda small boats crossing
the channel in the last decade the UK
has given over 250 million pounds in
funding to French authorities and they
still keep coming Rishi sunak believes
his predecessors took the wrong approach
If we're honest the relationship between
our two countries has had its challenges
but I believe today's meeting does Mark
A New Beginning
this means concrete action from the
French to help stop small boats
we're announcing a new Detention Center
in northern France a new Command Center
bringing our enforcement teams together
in one place for the first time and an
extra 500 new offices patrolling French
beaches all underpinned by more drones
and other surveillance technologies that
will help ramp up the interception rate
the small print he didn't say on stage
that means nearly half a billion more
funding to French authorities over the
next three years
the president's tone warm but says to
return migrants to the EU Britain must
work well with Brussels not an agreement
between UK and France but an agreement
between Yuki and the EU
because Dublin agreement are no more in
a situation to be implemented so this is
something now to be negotiated
Richie's seeing that closed this Summit
declaring the Anton was renewed and he's
certainly succeeded in transforming the
tone of the relationship with the UK's
closest neighbors but he needs to
convince the country and his party that
this is the right approach that
collaboration doesn't involve more
compromise than confrontation which was
the way Boris Johnson and Liz trust did
it and that has been made Harder by the
fact he's just written a check to the
French for half a billion pounds
the Pomp and platitudes of a summit
leave big questions and answered how
will the Detention Center work
will more money finally mean fewer
Crossings
Rishi sunx reset continues next stop the
United States being popular with fellow
leaders doesn't mean votes at home
however for that grand promises need to
come good and quickly Sam coat Sky News
Paris
to the weather and there's no immediate
respite in sight over the heavy snow
which has blanketed much of the UK last
night drivers were left stranded on the
m62 for hours and they weren't alone
or there are yellow weather warnings for
snow and ice in place tomorrow across
much of England and Scotland our
Midlands correspondent Becky Johnson
reports from Derbyshire
you know it's bad when even a snowplow
gets stuck here on the a53 in Derbyshire
all they could do was try to dig it out
that's why that's because the Grits has
got to score
in the end a local farmer came to their
rescue and they had to admit defeat
further down the road over the Border in
staffordshire they were trying to clear
it from the other end but they'd been
out here since the snow fell on Thursday
evening and these are six-wheel drive it
was in six-wheel drive and they were
they weren't going anywhere you couldn't
see anything
frightening really like Armageddon
really and drivers who had attempted it
soon regretted it
even after several hours of trying this
section of the road is proving
impossible to get through even with a
snowplow
abandoned cars lined the roads after the
snow came thick and fast on the m62
drivers who left Manchester late on
Thursday were trapped in their cars
overnight as the motorway ground to a
halt we
um but I was like we need to take
blankets we need to take coats just in
case in the Peak District some people
were snowed in with Derbyshire police
warning not to attempt to travel in the
area airports were affected too in
Birmingham they had to clear the runway
to keep planes moving
in Northern Ireland more than 200
schools were closed due to the weather
with many more shut across large parts
of northern England Wales and Scotland
but on there with the little trees for
people like Charlotte who found the
roads to her home in Staffordshire
blocked the only option was to travel on
foot
so what what can you do just sit and
wait for plows and snow blowers to come
through and then
wait for spring
but it could get worse before it gets
better more snow is forecast in places
and as all this melts ice will be the
biggest risk for large parts of the UK
this weekend Becky Johnson Sky News in
Staffordshire
a witness at the trial of the man
accused of murdering Olivia Pratt
Corbell says the nine-year-old's alleged
killer visited her on the night of the
shooting the jury also heard how
Olivia's brother held his sister after
she was shot but he said he knew it was
all over Katarina matazi reports from
Manchester Crown Court
on the night she died Olivia Pratt
Corbell was home in her pajamas with her
mum her older brother Ryan and sister
Chloe
Ryan Cobell told police he heard three
loud bangs from outside in the road the
next thing I heard was footsteps Across
The Landing it was Olivia she was
running downstairs screaming mum I'm
scared the jury heard him in a statement
say he saw Joseph knee slumped injured
in their hallway and a gunman outside
trying
what he didn't realize in that moment
was that his little sister had been shot
in the chest hit by a bullet that had
first gone through their front door and
her mother Cheryl's hand he said my mum
put live in my arms and told me to keep
pressure on her chest her lips had gone
blue she wasn't even bleeding out of the
gunshot wound I knew it was over
the jury will also played the witness
statement of a woman who can't be named
for legal reasons but in it the woman
told the police that she had known
Thomas Cashman for a few years and at
times their relationship had been
intimate she told police that on the
night that Olivia was shot she was at
home asleep and woke up to Thomas
Cashman repeatedly tapping her on the
leg and asking her for clean clothes
I could just hear him saying give me a
pair of pants she told the police he was
very nervous do you know what I mean
I've never seen him like that that's why
I felt like there was something wrong
she said she heard Thomas Cashman who's
34 say the name Joey knee and later say
I've done Joey
Thomas Cashman denies going to this
witness's house and all of the charges
against him including the attempted
murder of Joseph knee and the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia
Katrina fertazzi Sky News Manchester
Last Summer the predictions were clear
the UK was set for recession this winter
that now looks unlikely but the picture
is of stagnation instead the economy
grew by 0.3 in January more than the 0.1
percent that had been predicted however
looking back across the last two years
we see a changing picture three
significant dips in the last year after
the rebound that followed the end of
lockdown our business correspondent Paul
Kelso reports from Cambridge on the
factors holding back growth
in the Deep Freeze could be the future
of medicine human cells grown to order
in a lab outside Cambridge that's
pushing the boundaries of Biotech what
bid bio has created what is a process by
which we can recreate every human cell
type there's really no limit to how big
this company could become
the company's already valued at 200
million dollars the sort of business
that could give a boost to flatlining
GDP but the founder sees barriers to
expansion in Britain they put a new
building up and you know the space is
snapped up immediately
it's extremely competitive there's
constraints when it comes to of course
infrastructure and support of
infrastructure whether it's
manufacturing elsewhere you would get
governments that pay for your
manufacturing infrastructure to maximize
the potential of Cambridge and Oxford
government had planned to link the
cities with the ox Camp Arc a new road
Railway and a million homes in a British
answer to Silicon Valley but local
opposition means only the railway line
survives
you cannot put a california-sized biohub
on an East anglian Market town without
doing a bucket load of damage the point
is not no growth the point is good
growth if the UK is going to be a global
leader in the knowledge economies of the
future it won't do it without Cambridge
or Oxford or London perhaps a bigger
challenge though is trying to take what
works here and replicate it in parts of
the country that have been left behind
travel 200 miles north to Rochdale and
you find different barriers to growth
productivity and life expectancy are
below average here greater Manchester's
mayor says that Gap is holding the
economy back
people have likened it to a plane flying
on one engine and that kind of approach
to overheating London the southeast has
kind of it's taken us so far but it's
kind of it's creating a sense of a
country where people don't feel that
they're getting
if you like equal equal treatment he's
backing Adam Valley an industrial Zone
to attract Advanced manufacturing but
that will take skills and the production
line for those starts here I've been
looking around for apprenticeships
closer to home and there's just it's
like Manchester and stuff
so if they are closer to all might
Rochdale it'll be amazing do you think
you can fulfill your Ambitions around
here oh yeah 100 born in the right place
at the right time I suppose
Britain hasn't got one growth problem
it's got several and fixing them won't
be easy the chancellor has a chance to
try in next week's budget Paul Kelso Sky
News
an unborn baby was amongst the victims
of a shooting at a Jehovah's Witness
building in Hamburg last night police
have identified the gunman as a 35 year
old who had been a member of the
congregation six people were killed in
the attack before the gunman took his
own life our Europe correspondent
Siobhan Robbins report from Hamburg
in Hamburg they're bringing out the Dead
people shot where they worshiped
victims of a man in the shadows this
figure by a window
the hail of bullets shows he had no
mercy
an unborn baby among those gunned down
inside a Jehovah's Witness Center
um
I'm a resident up here and I heard loud
gunshots so I went to the window to get
an idea of the situation
and then I saw that a man was shooting
out of the window with a firearm there
were people being carried out and there
were probably 25 shots at least that I
heard
shots were reported here around 9pm
police arrived in a matter of minutes
interrupting and horrific attack seven
dead including the seven-month-old
unborn child whose mother survived
shellshock neighbors say officers search
for accomplices before confirming the
lone gunman had shot himself
we got a message from the police that we
shouldn't leave the house and three
policemen came and searched all the
houses here they were probably looking
for a fugitive but afterwards they found
the one who is now dead
the man responsible named as Philip F
also once worshiped here before he left
police say the sports shooter fired more
than a hundred rounds of ammunition at
his former group
is
through the window the shooter shot into
the building got into the building
through the window and continued to
shoot
police said that the gunman was
previously investigated after they
received an anonymous tip that he may
not be suitable to Bear Firearms but
when they visited him they found he
hadn't broken any rules and at that
point legally they said they couldn't
take it any further
some will question if this could have
been prevented but for now this city
Mourns
still reeling from one of the worst
crimes in its recent history Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Hamburg
smother news now and Regulators in
California have taken the unusual step
of shutting down all branches and head
office of the bank State officials
closed the doors of Silicon Valley Bank
earlier today in a statement they said
all branches will reopen on Monday
Iran and Saudi Arabia have agreed to
re-establish diplomatic relations and
reopen their embassies after seven years
of tension the Breakthrough was agreed
following negotiations led by China
I just want to let you know on Monday
we'll have a special debate on the race
to become Scotland's first Minister our
political editor Beth Rigby will be
joined by the three candidates Kate
Forbes humza Youssef and Ash Regan
that's next Monday at 7 pm
it's an appeal that might resonate for
thousands of potential Army recruits who
love their online gaming join the
military and keep on playing but it
could increasingly be a reality for
training at least as our Science and
Technology editor Tom Clarke reports
more has just broken out over the Lake
District a helicopter has been shot down
and the situation is escalating
okay I'm going to uh start the Convoy
again it's an exercise of course but one
that's being carried out in an entirely
virtual environment that promises to
change the way we train our military it
allows us to have one single synthetic
environment which can be streamed to you
know anywhere in the world so players
can be in different parts of the world
it replicates the real world physics it
replicates a real world terrain
without using real fuel or ammunition
typhoon pilots fly over the same virtual
terrain jackpot acknowledged being used
by ground troops drone and satellite
intelligence teams feed them with
information in real time using
simulators for military training is
nothing new but massive improvements in
cloud computing power artificial
intelligence and machine learning
software as well as Hardware like
augmented reality headset now make it
possible to bring large numbers of
people into a simulated environment of
the real world and allow them to train
together in real time
the computing power is large enough for
AI to represent 60 000 civilians in the
environment which alter their behavior
individually according to the battle
around them in this team all of them
need to see different things but they
need to see it in a common operating
picture keeping that up to date in real
time with 60 000 AI entities running
around and adapting to an emerging
situation is a complex computational
task so we are the plumbing that sits
underneath that
if it looks like a computer game well
that's because it is Hayden has worked
with the developers of games like
Minecraft to help scale their Virtual
Worlds
but isn't real war very different it's
important that the Armed Forces keep up
with the expectations of the younger
generation where they're now very
versatile on this equipment My worry is
because of pressures on budgets that we
will see the flight simulators we will
see these digital classrooms take over
from getting out into the field and
doing real life experience because in a
world of hypersonic missiles and
autonomous drones that experience is
changing too For Better or Worse
computers already fight much of our
battles make sense to train with them
too
Tom Clark Sky News Lancashire
now it could be a clear signal from the
King to his family about the value in
which he holds hard work that was the
suggestion of one historian we spoke to
today over the decision to make Prince
Edward and his wife Sophie the new Duke
and Duchess of Edinburgh they are
famously amongst the family's most
hard-working members as our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock reports
they've just been made Duke and Duchess
of Edinburgh so where else to Mark the
moment
oh is that how you say that for all of
them don't you absolutely
well all smiles arriving at the city
Chambers and meeting members of the
Ukrainian community
as birthday presents go this takes some
beating one of the country's most senior
titles now gifted from a big brother to
a little brother
I think that if you like King Charles
wants to show to reflect the importance
of people who are working for the
monarchy and who knows perhaps by
implication sideline a little people who
aren't
and with the Duke of York and the Duke
of Sussex no longer working Royals it
recognizes Prince Edward's growing role
and responsibilities
his father Prince Philip was the last
Duke of Edinburgh setting up the awards
scheme which bore his name huge shoes to
fill and significantly Prince Edward
can't pass the title to his son James
now Earl of Wessex the Palace of
thinking creatively about these types of
matters at the moment and perhaps how
we're moving towards a more role-based
monarchy where you get titles as a
result of your role in the monarchy
rather than as of right
honors the wishes of the
decision and another sign of what his
slimmed down monarchy will look like
Laura bundock Sky News
[Music]